I don't want to characterize it in the
wrong way and there's a lot of different
definitions but I think existential is
ultimately
do think that there is meaning
in sort of
pursuing The Passion of life like
pursuing the mo like in living life
that's where you discover the meaning at
that individual level
of fully embracing life
and I think sort of nihilism
is uh again it's kind of like a spectrum
but now listen basically says
there's no meaning
and it doesn't matter
nothing matters
I don't even know but somehow that lands
you in a place that's totally uninspired
maybe not list would disagree with that
maybe there's a way to live a creative
life in in a nihilistic mindset and I
think of absurdism is somewhere in the
middle
where
pursuing meaning at all
is not a good idea
so kind of I think existentials say you
should be looking for meaning and it's
to be discovered in your own actions in
your own life in the moment and uh
absurdism says life is absurd nothing
makes sense don't look for the meaning
just live just be I think that's kind of
the the the later kamu kind of
um philosophy I don't know if you can
sort of comment on these kind of nuanced
ideas here if there is no
religious guide to your life
um what do you think about this kind of
search for meaning do you see that
there's some wisdom and existentialist
perspective of discovering it in your
own life in this passion in this kind of
day-to-day existence in the moments of
your life that bring you Joy that kind
of thing you're bringing different sort
of perspectives and trying to tease
apart like wait what are the differences
in those perspectives right and I think
what it points out is that okay we tend
to conflate things as human beings right
and to take two different things and try
and make them into one but we also I
think on the other end of the spectrum
get very overly reductionist and I think
that when we get to overly reductionist
we lose the ability to learn from
anything or to generate meaning right I
mean think about Sartre who is you know
the thought of existentialism is so
consistent with him right who on the one
hand you know wrote about you know very
clear terms like this is what it is and
this is what it isn't and here's how
you're going to make your meaning in a
very like academically prescribed way
but he also wrote short stories like the
wall right where there's something
totally absurd happens right as part of
the story right so I I think what ends
up happening is people either reduce
themselves or get associated with
something that is by being overly
reductionist takes us away from meaning
right the idea that look we don't know
if there is a an overarching religious
meaning or you know what we call a
religious meaning or purpose like we
don't know that right so so okay if we
take that as a given that people who say
that they know are having faith look at
how Spinoza described Faith right faith
is that you don't know but you believe
anyway right it's not because you have
faith now you know something right
because I think that's a slippery slope
to the persecution of others right so so
if we say okay we don't know
then
you know we're left either deciding okay
well then to hell with everything you
know like is that movie A Strange Brew
right either Bob and Doug McKenzie where
like the breaks don't work on the car
and one of them says oh why bother
steering right so if we don't know that
there's meaning like why bother stealing
let's just give up the ghost right and I
don't think that's even what the
nihilist said I mean I think the coonan
said we should get rid of everything
that we've ever created except
Beethoven's Ninth Symphony and start
over from there but so even people who
are very nihilistic or associated with
that yeah a lot of them are just not
liking what we had built right so if we
accept that a lot of what we have built
as humans inside of us and outside of us
is really counterproductive and doesn't
help us and that absurd things happen in
the world right and that often the way
social structures and systems build up
you build themselves up is absurd I
think our health care System operates in
a way that's absurd right so if we
accept that there are absurdities that
we don't know if there's truth then what
are we left with but like well let's try
and make meaning right or take it you
got set said um yoso yo Amy
circumstancia right I myself and my
circumstances right which is like look
we're we can't control everything we we
live in circumstances around us but
within those circumstances we can make
decisions and Define ourselves and and I
think the Brilliance of that and I think
tying it all together right in a way
that's not trying to be in a sense it
ties it all together by not trying to
answer everything concisely that yes we
can make meaning like we see that if
someone trips in front of me I could
walk around them or I could help them up
I mean no one can tell me that it
doesn't matter what I do I I absolutely
reject the idea that oh I could step
over them or on them or I could help
them up and it doesn't matter oh yeah be
the try being the person on the ground
right so we create meaning but we live
in our circumstances and there are
absurdities both within us and outside
of us in our social structures and there
are a lot of things that that pretend to
have meaning that don't and there's the
shades of nihilism But ultimately
there's something going on here that's
doing the best we can in the context of
just not knowing
yeah I tend to see I don't know if it's
genetic I think I tend to think just
observing the internet the number of
memes there are uh
I think many other people are like me I
tend to see the the humor in the
absurdity
I tend to enjoy it from that kind of
angle I see the kafka-esque nature of
society of different aspects of society
and just kind of notice the magic with a
smile
and just laugh at the circus of it all
because it is magical that the circus
all comes together it's like a little
bit out of sync and then just a guy
playing trombone but like overall it's
pretty good it's pretty good right and
we can look at that and just kind of
Marvel and go yeah right which which I
think is a relation to at least a lot of
what we in the Western World think of as
Eastern right it's like as
non-attachment right because then if
there's something absurd and it's like
not good for me you know right then I
accept that too instead of getting angry
about it and railing about it or seeing
some Cosmic meaning in it right I think
there's also a healthy non-attachment in
what you're saying too